top story this hour aaa expects air
travel to rebound to near pre-pandemic
levels during the year-end holiday
travel period
that increase in passengers comes
airlines are still operating at reduced
capacity due to the pandemic leaders of
the four nation's four biggest airlines
testified together for the first time in
years at a senate hearing about their
readiness as chris van cleave reports
one ceo made a surprising comment about
wearing a mask
a rare sight on capitol hill the ceos of
american southwestern united as well as
a senior executive from delta sitting
side by side as senators fired questions
will we ever be able to get on an
airplane without masks i think the case
is
very strong that
masks don't add much after the hearing
southwest ceo gary kelly then tested
positive for kovitt despite being fully
vaccinated and boosted i'm shocked
that
some of the ceos here today
have suggested that we no longer
need mass mandates
on planes do you believe that we should
be lifting the mass mandate we agree
that it should continue to stay in place
it's a workplace safety issue senator ed
markey of massachusetts hammered the
execs over refunds for passengers who
canceled their flights during the
pandemic will you refund that money yes
or no we will give you a credit the
passengers want the money back and
you're not saying you're going to give
it to them and
at a minimum they just want a voucher
that they can use whenever they want to
stung by operational challenges that led
to thousands of canceled flights
american and southwest acknowledge the
pandemic has made it harder to quickly
recover from disruptions like severe
weather we had this unforecasted
situation in dallas we just where it's
very difficult to get people to
essentially not really volunteer for
work but republicans focused on united's
vaccine mandate as for the rapidly
approaching holidays you'll be back to
near 2019 levels of travel
can the airline industry handle that i
think we are we're getting back and all
the support services that we need
whether it's the tsa faa staffing fuel
vendors and look forward to clear skies
ahead the issue of disruptive passengers
also came up the flight attendants union
pleaded with senators to ban to-go
alcohol sold at airports saying about 60
percent of disruptive passenger cases
are linked to alcohol consumption and
those complaints have been off the
charts for cbs saturday morning i'm
chris van cleave in washington